as this crisis worsens health experts
have repeatedly warned that our national
response is just not enough
we are joined now by health and human
services secretary that's alex azar good
morning to you mr secretary good to see
you
first first let's start with kudos to
the trump administration because
operation warp speed
appears to be working the way you all
had hoped let's start with pfizer
breaking news this morning
that you've applied the fda is going to
apply for emergency youth authorization
what does that mean how soon could the
vaccine be available and to who
yeah gail it means that hope and help
are on the way pfizer filing today for
emergency use authorization
means that fda will very quickly
announce that we'll be scheduling a
public advisory committee process of
independent experts who will give fda
their best views on the data
and we if if the data is as solid as it
appears and if the company is
transparent in their interactions
we literally could be weeks away from
the authorization of a 95 percent
effective vaccine and we've said
24 hours later we'll ship millions of
doses of that vaccine and
within a couple of months between pfizer
and moderna's vaccine assuming they both
are approved
we will have vaccinated tens of millions
of america's most vulnerable citizens
okay let's hang on to that secretary but
let's talk about your news conference
yesterday
number one was great to see you guys we
haven't seen you in four months i'm
curious about why it took you so long to
come out and speak to the american
people
and let us know what's going on and
deborah burks pulled no punches she said
the numbers are going in the wrong
direction it's getting worse
what is happening here why can't we get
it under control
well the situation is very serious but
it's not one where the united states is
isolated we've seen this in western
europe and canada and the united states
i coordinate
across all the g7 health ministers and
it's a common phenomenon the people are
fatigued
people have given up they've sacrificed
so much over the last 10 months
and as we've gotten colder weather we've
moved indoors
and we've lost that kind of natural
social distancing that happens from
being outside
and we've gotten into household
gatherings of friends and family we've
gone to crowded indoor bars and
restaurants and
we let our guard down and we don't
practice the three w's of washing our
hands watching our distance and wearing
our face coverings when we can't do
those things and
that's what we have to do and that's
what can get this so we can bend the
curve as dr burks and dr fauci said
yesterday if we'll all just do those
things
yesterday president-elect joe biden said
that he's had no contact with the trump
administration
and this is a very dire situation as you
know he says every day that they don't
communicate it's costing lives
because ultimately they're going to have
to take control of this when do you plan
to speak to the biden administration
so we'll coordinate and talk as soon as
it's appropriate i'm going to leave that
transition planning to other individuals
right now what people need to know is
the coronavirus response
we're all on it operation warp speed but
what is it
those efforts but wait a second when is
it appropriate
gail there's a statute in place that
directs a process for that
what the american people need to know is
the same career people at cdc
fda defense department hhs that are
running this response in operation warp
speed
on january 19th are going to be the same
people on january 21st and
every aspect of what we do is completely
transparent there's no secret data or
knowledge
we've spent hours literally with the
public and the media this week
laying out every aspect of the
distribution planning on these vaccines
our epidemiological information
completely transparent are planning
everything so secretary is all out there
it sounds like you're saying that
that joe biden is incorrect when he says
this delay is going to cost
lives absolutely incorrect
all right all right leave it there all
right secretary azar thank you we have a
difference of opinion clearly but we
thank you for
your time this morning